- We're back with John
Hamm and Roy Wood Jr.,
everybody. Their new movie
is called "Confess, Fletch."
It's a who-done-it story of an art heist.
So, okay.
They're excited about the
game that I'm gonna win.
So in honor of their movie
it's time for a game
called, Artful Reveals.
(theme music for Artful Reveals)
It's me versus John versus Roy.
So, Lord Almighty. Are you there?
(harp music)
- Oh
- Uh Oh.
- [Lord Almighty] You bet I am, Kelly.
You liked that?
You liked that harp?
That was nice.
Wasn't it.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- [Lord Almighty] All
right now in this game
I'm gonna slowly reveal
an image of a famous work
of art or a famous movie
poster, one tile at a time.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Lord Almighty] Now, when
you know the name of the piece
of art or the movie, you're
gonna hit your button.
And you're gonna guess. If you're right
you're gonna hear this.
(bell dings)
- That's it-- I'mma hear it
- [Lord Almighty] And you can,
you can also gimme the name
of the artist or movie
star for a bonus point
but if you're wrong
(buzz sound)
- [Lord Almighty] Oh, I like that.
I'm gonna keep revealing the
image for the other players
but you cannot guess twice.
I'm talking to you, Kelly.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- [Lord Almighty] Okay.
Now John-- John or Roy.
If, if you guys win
you're gonna get your
photos up on the coveted
Chicks Wall of Champs.
- Oh, yeah? Okay.
- [Kelly] Chicks. Yeah.
- Alright, I like that.
- [Lord Almighty] Okay. Let's do this.
Here we go.
Here's your first one.
- Okay.
- [Lord Almighty] Here is
work of art number one.
- Okay. Okay.
- [Lord Almighty] Okay. Slowly revealing.
This could be anything.
- Yeah.
- What?
- [Lord Almighty] Could be-
(Kelly's Clarkson's buzzer dings)
- [Lord Almighty] Oh!
- Is it... Is it Mona Lisa?
I don't know.
- [Lord Almighty] It is! It is Mona Lisa!
(Kelly Clarkson screams)
(audience applauds)
- Pew pew pew pew pew!
- A little suspense there.
- [Lord Almighty] Okay, now,
now you are correct Kelly.
Now for a bonus point, do you
know the name of the artist?
- Oh, God.
Don't make me look stupid.
I honestly I'm so sorry.
- It's Lisa Irena!
- It's
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- No it isn't!
- It's one of the Ninja Turtles right?
- [Lord Almighty] I'm sorry
John that's incorrect.
- I don't know.
And I even saw it in person.
I just, yeah, I don't remember.
I'm sorry.
- [Lord Almighty] I'm so sorry.
It was Da Vinci.
- One of the Ninja Turtles!
That's what I said!
- [Lord Almighty] Yeah, that's right.
We would've accepted Donatello,
Raphael, or Michelangelo.
- I, I could have named every one of them.
So that explains who I am.
- [Lord Almighty] I understand.
Alright, Here's the next one.
We're gonna slowly reveal this one.
Now pay attention, fellas.
- Okay.
- [Lord Almighty] Here we go.
Coming at you.
- Oh, I know this
- Pulp Fiction?
- Yep.
- [Lord Almighty] It is Pulp Fiction.
(audience applauds)
- [Lord Almighty] That is correct!
You're finally on the board here.
And can you name some folks
in that motion picture?
- Well that's not fair it's
- Well, it's written on the title?
- Yeah!
- [Lord Almighty] Well, that's cheating.
Well, that's you cheating.
- Want me to name the director?
- [Lord Almighty] Name the producer.
Yeah, name the producer.
- It only cost a dime.
That was the great thing about it.
- [Lord Almighty] I'll give it to you too.
That's right. Sure.
Well, John, he got two points.
Just for making up some stuff.
How about that?
Here? A bonus point.
What was in the suitcase, John?
- Uh. A very bright light.
No one knows what was in the suitcase.
- [Lord Almighty] That is correct.
We'll give you that too.
- Oh, I don't remember that.
- He opens the suitcase and it--
- I don't. I know. I don't know.
I haven't seen it in-
- [Lord Almighty] Alright. Moving on,
here is your next one.
- I'm just kidding.
- I'm not.
- [Lord Almighty] I'm
going to move this slowly.
Taking away those tiles.
Any guesses?
(Roy Wood Jr's buzzer dings)
- What?
- [Lord Almighty] I'm just
having fun back here now.
- The Last Supper.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- [Lord Almighty] It is the last supper.
- Another turtle, another turtle.
- [Lord Almighty] Which one of
the turtles painted this one?
- [Kelly] I think you're the only one--
- I think that was Michelangelo.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Lord Almighty] It was not Michelangelo.
- It wasn't Michelangelo?
- [Lord Almighty] No, I'm sorry.
You cannot guess any longer.
- It was Master Splinter?
- [Lord Almighty] Sure. Why not?
- [Kelly] Master Splinter?
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
(buzz sound)
- I dunno this either.
- [Lord Almighty] Okay.
John, Kelly, you have a
guess on who painted the Last Supper?
- I- Da Vinci. I don't know, I'm nam--
(bell dings)
(Kelly screams)
- [Lord Almighty] It is Da Vinci!
(audience applauds)
(Kelly mouths "oh my gosh")
- I'm on fire.
Look at him right now.
- [Lord Almighty] Here's the next one.
Reveal it slow.
Everybody pay close attention now.
(cowbell dings)
- [Lord Almighty] Oh and that sound means
it's our final one.
Our final image.
- This, this one gotta be for 10 points.
- [Lord Almighty] This is for 20 points.
I'm gonna make this 20 points. Okay?
- Oh my god!
(audience whoops and applauds)
- [Lord Almighty] You read my mind.
You know how this works.
Here it comes.
Reveal that graphic.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Lord Almighty] Okay. Roy.
- Come on! Titanic.
- [John] Ohhh!
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Lord Almighty] It is Titanic.
- Titanic.
- Starring Leonardo Da Vinci.
(John and Kelly laughs)
- [Lord Almighty] That's right!
Starring Leonardo Da Vinci.
Close enough.
I'll give it to you.
(airhorn blows)
- [Lord Almighty] Well, there you go.
That's our game.
- That's the game.
And Roy is the big winner.
Cause God, it's cheating.
It's fine.
(buzz sound)
- Your photo's now mounted after the show
on the Chicks Wall of Champs.
Are you excited about this moment?
- [Roy] Yes!
Yes.
- [Kelly] Would you like to thank anyone?
- Yes.
- Would you like to thank anyone?
- I'd like to thank my mama
watching this at home
in Birmingham on NBC 13.
(Kelly laughs)
- Philly shout out.
- That was nice. That was nice.
Thank you guys so much for playing!
And everyone remember to see
Confess, Fletch. It's in
theaters and on demand now.